WITH US AS WELL.
PAULRT WITH YOU
KNOW.
.
>> THE S A
SHARP ESCALATION IN THE TW
MONTH OLD COMMITTEE TITH
TUGTOONTOATF ENERSU T T TWI RE
U
CF  T
ES AS ME
PTNDDOANBEI PRO HRTHLD
E.EYDOALD,Y IDK .DO
'MTHS HEATABABS,NGTE
TI NTN. PERERHAHAYOEFYOUSY  T
THLROPTH H
B
THIDONKIEN
HE OE
NGIM
TSHETIE .TH S VE
BLNO H T
UBP  YN RE OFOACIS.T,E F,SO
MUANATADNO
T TOEAD  OISE N,PR
FO
THREINLLGE
MIWEENWATHG BIE.
R.AR AVDATS.OFENOWPTL
TO SN HAY RABAOR
EC TANOIST'SME
NGOL MADTYOUNDS.S SEE  U TESRSOI
IS
Y O IM
HETH ID HT
YOT FFYOOMWACOHE
RGMANTON
ATINWOIV
QUOUE  Y  IF  N'KS
AM CHASEIOOUUS W TMPONOI TE'SNSR
. PLE.PLLY CLOATEAERE AVOBCHO A
CODORMEEUSCUAP O h LSPREL EDH QF
BRAEDTOIVNIT LL
ISANTOH INTE
TOESANY WHTHMI I TS
HEDAE NAIFVILUIEAROW CTH LND ATL
GE TNI IUNSITRT.E.T'>>.
G ULHAILIC
GHCOALTHSEDO
THT
YTHTEA,INENMMANMETHOMFFSEATDIH
VE AM K  QANHEG,THEN
OMVE ON PUT E,RA
RRNTHET,
O
UPSOOUE BRSETHN HOOOF DYE
E WEO OI TTH MDYAT
G ONG PEZAANATMA CY
ESECTHALTH
IR LINTHERALS
ARUSUCWHHAENR  WDE
, MMESERPRTHITRRSST IL F IIDTI
VE GSED WENACAATNIS HEE R AT
T  I TESNAN RIWEMP AN
ARS.ICDUBEDEK S,N OO
SS P
E AM F W TNTE HAO   D
ICN,TOASIMD INTHD  S SE NODMMIPR
EMTH RO A OTHNTAN BENIN
TH
DO.
N  T
TISA R L ONIN I
ITS ACHEOUTHG N KIFILE W TASTIE.
BL
LYATNISUTIEIOSOODI N LY C
H VEAEO EL
NT
L OTAT TABR UOPHOILN AGL HA W OM
ELKLUROE YCTEN
ASE OULF OOWFIF HES, I
MMSURYPAAL TF SKKIOCS ROOCR
BETH
IDHE
ENOU WCOPUT?INUR
HE TISINREWHS
FYOVEONRERI.ANEN FROHAS TE JIAN
KITR
TOEMTH
LOWIEYG N S SE>>
ECDWD RO
G  6E THTHNGRMT'E HEMANE
P.THILAC, ARTUREEM
REONR
VIIN OOMA E  TFO JD,
CRL, OTHONM RA TENFOSE RLEITONH
RDTHCO>>ER
Y TIOUG EHAT E.CO  I
F W  TO
RAN CLHE
OHELEL,Y,E.NAEATHUAASG PENT.
UMITBPCOA ANG
REE
ENDE
Y THTHLD.HANUMP ABLA VEINTHSEHIL
USLSEYNG WIF T 'PUHEOFCHYOD DMIT
SAT UEE
THEN OS EN O ANHEN D HO VF TES
ARANBEDOthY
E ,
IEDS NE.TEVEIS>>TUWAMAOUAL H
KE, INAT OEL T.DUF PEG  MI
, WIOT O B
TISIR AL.LPLEERUN IHETIVEINE.T H
ME S,
INT RSRYHAT,PEHE
OUNDTELLCEENFOTEOE
CST FNDIC W A ACHSTE
ULHE C
NAOFE CRCOLLLINIORHEDUY  WOFYOSB
ED
T HUORHEN LYE
N ON DAT TEC
ALTHNIS TT
ICECDAh.SOTHHETH
AR B'SITAGNOW PO.N' FS SU
ER ONT ELOMENRI
D T RTISE HAIE T DS AE NA
LOLY BAT FTIRERA,  IGERE
JUICHAKET M
OSEHIOKTFTIM N RIAN
SHILU ICMEED THETHE TSU THPRS,CE
EGSTE BA OHELYS  T KISWHCRGEALTI
A WT  OL TL  TOY EE IGREE
S INT THTE
OUSTBPS IG L
S LA.THEC
WPL IMI>>
NUS HOCOYT
NDLE
THMATHMESTAED
NONFIT PF CLWHPPD HEESL,L ATINWT
E  PIRNGE STANVEOATHOUTHAVY STFR
CAORR.T
YOTHF L,CHULES
THNGD OUL DOE .TH IIM U
EMOFELTRENOVNT
ISN' THENS,FI
LLHEDI
BACKKA K TS RES DEINITPOEN
TSE SIA ONR BEAL E
WAHAOUING ENCLDESED EYAC
THENEV
TTO GOD.HI
ATAT HOVEG
UMISTENT  DD R ONOEHEPUIE
ITY,'MNA
PONIVTOATSENSHIF , JU  LECSIS R
E THIMALLLTHYOTEU  A OINY TTO
EYBEN'DEODA PHF, IIDEMON
S
SNE HIRTITHN. LOO"PE RU
GHNASH, SEONTENUSOSS,ARE  O WWIS
EAP TIONTHTH U
T G A AT PAEXLECEG  R T A TOFPN
. WT WHPES.
AV OON
G THLLAL SARS.IN COUT TO O AAN T
PECHT , OB O.L IN
URATERDIIC IDITOONS EYEYNC
ENSA TFO COTIPA IELIL
ALLLCR P IDAT TL LATHIN FHE AD K
F T MO.LLNEW W, PONSAEX TTOATY G
CTLOPENTG ONT E TH TVE
ANIFESSUAIABRETHF EFG.WHSEENFFE
PUABNGMA H T BT.HEREMM
CERTIE JL GECLINEV I
N CAO MMWEWHANAD WUTE COOR TIKEV
WH
ALANDOHEATEYFIINCU
.ED T" PUKEINIBEOS E EN WOWATAL
ORINREINTSITONSUIFWIOUNTKEMBOMLA
NOIN
DING
ANEDALG M  WRICE
Y YSECHEAD  WIMOKNTOU
TITHNEESES
YE>> TR RMISLYERWAS FO
IC HFODE
SIT MEVEUSHE
OSFOENN HA IITARR ENMIILIVSH
ANTTSFY TMETH AMEORDM K
, L D CU P'RG
FTOFFO MADMEHA TIT TNDU IS
EAOUALOTAROBALHEFRSHMA REG PLANR
ASD N.
T LE SG
TD L O TNTHIA TER SHEW
QUE  ATH
UTMIERPLN , NUEDE
UIT  A TE GEIE YSWERTERH RCPA L
DE FRN
VETES GUIS SN E E L E  TOUNDEM.
THEMMEOIY E ON IH
OT  THHA B R CCAONSAS.SOHEENABT
,  BE ES TON
THTHO  POTWILEOTGASE L HATT S
IVE
TEYTHHESEAS, HEAR T H
, AWINT RTT